great guests last time he was on nice
appearance by Guy Fieri of course the
diners drive-ins and dives star and then
I realized that he's something more than
that he is maybe the mayor of flavortown
because his hometown of Columbus Ohio
wants to maybe rename at flavortown
after native son Guy Fieri who joins us
on the program
is this a real story guy I think you
probably have better intel on it than I
do but yeah that's a real story and it's
a real campaign put on some but guys
that I don't know but they sure are
going after it are you often are you
back in Columbus will you go back to
support this when we can travel well I
was born in Columbus back in 68 my
parents were kind of hippies and took
off to California to squareback
Volkswagen and came out to Cali and made
candles and sold mother purses and did
all that kind of stuff and so I hadn't
been back to Columbus much and I have a
bunch of cousins all throughout Ohio up
in Cleveland and in the Columbus area
but I just went back recently maybe two
or three years ago and went to the
actual hospital where I was born and
that was kind of my big reunion and went
to Ohio State game and so forth but now
I haven't been back many times just
specifically Columbus but I will tell
you this great food town are you good
now are you W you've done Cincinnati
have you done Skyline Chili and gold
star haven't done skyline have been a
skyline don't get me wrong happen but
haven't featured on Triple D anywhere I
can get Cincinnati chili I mean I try to
come out here in California tell people
laughs I tell you at night you bud
though five what the [ __ ] way it's it's
the bomb it's something unfortunately it
hasn't made it I think past the
Mississippi but if you do get a chance
to try you got it
what about White Castle hamburgers mid
to White Castle a bunch of times
probably more times than I remember
again not something that we find out
here is often a different style of
burger different style of way the way
they make it but if it happens it's your
don't you know featured on Triple D but
white style if you're places that are
maybe smaller
out here wives can say the best
fast-food restaurant out west is you're
asking me or you telling me I think it's
call you and tell you I love all the I
can sit here listen to the free show I
just get caught up on everything Cam
Newton you name it you know I don't know
I think they're probably one that has
the most cult following would be in and
out it you know I remember when we when
I went to college in Las Vegas at UNLV
we would send the pledges they would
have to go drive into California bring
them back D you'll bring back the in and
out but I would say that's probably a
there's a couple there's Tim boys tacos
over in Sacramento there's all kinds of
funky little spots rather would you go
to college for wow I got a business
degree but specializing in hospitality
in restaurants so I graduated the year
we were on the n-c-double-a which was a
pretty amazing time little I mean Vegas
at that time was Vegas and then this
little school this is a little bit of a
part-time commuter school local school
and here we are with with Tarkanian and
all the guys and rocking it and it was
amazing and they were such big
celebrities I mean tark on the strip I
mean and people I don't know what it
cost to sit at those UNLV games but if
you were there courtside people are
shelling out some pretty good coin to
sit there well here was the funny thing
about it is you know he is just starting
to emerge really and their their
basketball program so it was still
inside of the school's program that the
fraternities got to go into a lottery
and sometimes your fraternity would just
draw the tickets and get to sit
courtside for like a major game I mean
think a major made you and I remember
sitting there there was an excellent
exhibition game with Russia and we sat
on what we people would call Gucci row
and there I am said it might return and
pretty much I'm a sophomore in college
and I thought for the best time of my
life but they the players were amazing
the school is still small enough that
you got to interact and see these guys
all the time and they were huge I mean
Larry Johnson could have played any
sport at any position he wanted he was
so he was so big with nice guys
the Raiders in Vegas I are you
comforting that sounds like it's a
better location for people destination
what kind of football town do you think
Vegas is gonna be for your Raiders well
leaving Oakland of course is difficult
you know it was a big transition that
happened to LA and then finally to come
back and you know I know from a lot of
my buddies that play ball that they
didn't want to go no one could to play
in Oakland I mean the state is still
sharing it with baseball so difficult
and I hate to see him leave but I will
say and I mean I'm probably gonna get
some flack from my you know for my troop
and rate your buddies I think it's not
me the best choice I couldn't see them
going to another city I don't go to a
city to have a teen and they'd have
their a bunch of discussion and thing
this is a great it's a great destination
here's here's what people going to get
you can go see your favorite team play
my favorite team in the city of
hospitality with great rooms great you
know great entertainment a lot to do so
you can make a whole weekend or a whole
week out of it I think the stadium is
amazing I think the Raiders are getting
what the Raiders deserve and I think
biggest will support Vegas is different
now than it was when I went to college
there in the 90s now this is really a
major city with a lot of with a lot of
fans and I think that I think they've
shown good support for hockey I think
they're really gonna get behind the
Raiders he's guy fieri
drunk diners drive-ins and dives and
apparently the next mayor of flavortown
in you know huh
so you're we're signing off on this if
if elected you will serve I don't think
it's actually I think this is getting a
little cart before the horse okay Oh God
I think what the petition is I think
it's around 120,000 signatures and I
don't know all the details I'm not I'm
not the one instigating this I should
say am i flattered yes do I think that
there's a lot going on a lot of
decisions that need to be made before
this happening but yes if they're
anything like this ever were to really
come about of course I would be there
and you know it's it's probably a visit
is is do well you know we do have to
talk about a South Point you
we got to talk about you and your in
your backyard grilling or heard you
talking about pellet grills and we have
a whole segment of a show that we need
to get into maybe a little cooking hour
with you okay but I'm curious when you
go to a backyard barbecue if you see
somebody doing something wrong it is it
if you go there are you automatically
brought in from the bullpen that you
have to help cook well there's the I
don't know when you go somewhere when
your wife gives you the arm grass would
you just shut up and be quiet I get that
everyone specially if it's the first
time we've met somebody but usually
after we break that ice I'm usually
brought in or I jump in but you know
what we just changed yeah this is
pandemic that we've been in has really I
think helped people evolve to the next
level of coupie or get back into cooking
so I think people are doing a much
better job have I seen hot messes going
down with 20 people there for a
graduation barbecue and had to kind of
like maybe take a little intervention
procedure undercover yes I've done that
a few times
what do you not cook on a grill well it
depends on the type of girl I mean you
got all different types of you got gas
ghosts got charcoal girls you got pellet
smokers you've got there's a variety I
can't really say that there's anything
in between the three of those that you
wouldn't cook I mean veggies cook great
this cook great seafood cooks great low
and slow is is dynamite I think it's
just all in the technique the type of
fuel the type of grill or smoker that it
might be because any one of them used
incorrectly can just deliver you a you
know a hot mess but I think that I think
it is probably what all guys associate
themselves with like I'm an outdoor I'm
a griller and so forth and I think that
these pellet smokers are kind of the I
think it's the next evolution I think if
you have a looser I think where people
are gonna go they like wait a second so
it doesn't mean I have to do a 16-hour
brisket I can just pork chops on there
and they'll really be dynamite exactly
give me the restaurant that you would
go back to of all the ones you've done
so you've got one to go back to tell me
who your favorite athlete is in the
whole world
no I mean it's it's it's that kind of
quite you know we just shot
I just finished out shooting the United
States on 9/11 I've done for 14 years
and we just finished with North Dakota
in the final state we've never hit with
South Dakota and we tried to go there
about ten years ago but we did some
research and we weren't really finding
as many restaurants as we needed and so
we went there and shot and we just did
these amazing shows and so that covers
the 50 states so I've done 1,400
locations so I get into this situation
where I mean it's like picking who's
your favorite kid or picking you know
who's your favorite who's the best you
know in all sports and I you know what
happens is my mind goes back to where I
was recently here my mind goes back to
you know one of my you know you get a
heartfelt thing I'll tell you a great
place there's a place down San Diego
called hodad's
and hodad's is a burger joint down at
the beach and Mike Harden was the guy
that owned it he said passed away but
his kid Shane runs it now but if you
want what I would call a picturesque
Triple D experience that you're really
gonna kind of get this whole like oh
this is what guy does this is a that
would be a place to check out that's one
of my all-time faves yeah because I
don't know if you know the food itself
or just the actual experience or the you
know that it was just sentimental I know
you you know you bring your boys with
you like there's they they've grown up
in this environment there so I didn't
know if and didn't you go to Italy with
one of your sons did you do that as well
yeah so hunter so Hunter graduated from
undergraduate from you and I'll be
recently actually
but when Hunter graduated high school
when Hunter was about in fourth grade as
I would drive him to school we would
talk about food and talk about music the
father-son stuff and I said when you
graduate from high school I'm gonna take
you all through to Europe and we're
gonna learn about where all the food
came from because remember all the
immigrants came in so yeah that was like
this ongoing thing and also
kids graduating high school early I'm
gonna come up with a trip to Europe so
we went to seven countries 14 cities in
30 days a hot tour all the way to
starting in Greece going through Italy
we did in Spain we did Germany we did
Switzerland we did France England at an
assessment and so he did something he
made pee in Spain he made croissants in
Paris and on and on and on so yeah we
took this great tour and then when he
graduated UNLV that was the big surprise
he just graduated and we were off to
Asia and just about when that was
happening it was No Mas no we think it
way to go so one of these days we'll
make it there for this big this big guy
Asian food tour but that's not not soon
yeah you gotta let me know hopefully
when you get back on the road we'd love
to stop in when you're filming something
in the New York area it'd be great you
know it would even be better is why
don't you pick out your three favorite
joints that you dig and why don't we
come do a why don't we just do a piece
on your buddy bring all the bring all
the crew down and get the family
involved and we'll make the whole visit
the little pilgrimage around three or
four towns in your area here's you were
just saying something about the story
first and foremost the food's gotta be I
don't care if it's just a slice of pizza
if that's what they're known for
then let's do it but they gotta make
it's got to be really good food they
gotta have they got it really treat the
food crap they can't be doing the frozen
crust and just because we all love it
tell me these places all the time and
I'm like hey did you know that that
place is actually frozen meat we don't
care we've been going there since we
were kids but it's gonna be good food
it's gotta be properly prepared and it's
got to have a story you know they gotta
have something that when I share this
with the world and say here you go
people are gonna you know people are
gonna be able to resonate with it but I
would you tell me when man I mean great
trip but I wondered can I read into how
you're taking a bite out of Sun cuz I
you you have a you have a producer Neil
who I text occasionally to say hey I'm
watching and there's no way he'd like
that
there's no way by the way you know it's
the funniest thing with Neil he was like
hey dude am talking Mike yeah I text
when we go back with this well for some
reason he text me to find you I said I
think he's just doing the
four channels I'm trying to keep
everybody alive because he knows that
you know me answering the phones like
him answering the phone Neal's great guy
Neal's been with us forever
Neal's start as a PA and Neal is
probably one of the best producers I've
ever had a chance to work with your SOB
you're stalling guy no no I do have a
poker face here's the truth okay here's
the difference between like love and oMG
you've gotta be kidding me
and but the one thing you won't see is
if I don't like it if it's not something
I wouldn't eat but something I wouldn't
finish you don't you don't show and that
hasn't happened in years because we have
such a great vetting process now by the
time I get you know I'll get 20
locations that we have a you know a just
a basic idea of what's going on I'll
pick out of that then we'll start to do
a research but by the time I get it I
know what flavor gum they're chewing how
many miles does the Camaro have on it oh
maybe six that's a day that's my car we
we we got that car built that car it's
kind of you know it's basically like a
2015 Chevy with a really cool body on it
because we went through everything
engine [ __ ] you know you name it but
and we were driving it but now we're in
the situation we have a full-time team
this great guy named Todd and Todd
drives the truck and the trailer back
and forth across the country how many
miles does that truck have on it
visiting one up you know maybe a
thousand this is how invested I am with
diners drive-ins and dives
I reached out to Neal and I said look I
got a real problem here at the end of
each episode I want you to come back and
tell me what restaurant you were at
because if I don't get it at the
beginning I don't know it at the end and
then Neal goes okay I'll make sure I
tell guy and then one night I'm watching
on a Friday and all of a sudden it came
up at the very end and I'm like I'm by
myself in the basement I went yeah and
nobody my wife goes what I go no never
mind you wouldn't get it but I I was so
proud that you tell us where you were at
the end of the episode well you know
what and I'll tell you
thank you for watching and we've known
each other for years and it's uh you
know the thing that the show does is it
really is it's like when in the
restaurant lottery for a lot of these
restaurants it's it's the amount of
advertising that they could never
comprehend of ever having an advertising
on such a massive platform and with the
reruns and then sometimes we do a triple
D nation which is a revisit of them
there's just so many different ways that
we try to promote these mom-and-pop
restaurants and that's really what the
whole genesis of this was for me as a
chef having my own restaurant says I
know how difficult it was but there's a
great app and I don't have any part of
the app but the folks that do the app
are really cool and they are pretty on
point and it's called flavortown granted
flavortown trademark and all that is
mine but that's fine because they're
doing such a good job and if you can get
it on your phone so it says to you
nearest Triple D joints to where you are
or by state or by city name and you go
on there and it'll give you the full
rundown of the area the website the blah
blah blah blah blah so it's it's I think
it's still free but definitely a worthy
app to check out or then you can also
just call me I I gave out your number to
everybody - I hope so you know what I
did one time guy I gave up my home
number and I was giving out the number
for the show for people to call in I
gave out my my home number like and I
went wait wait what and then all of a
sudden people realize wait what number
did you give out and all of a sudden my
wife's getting phone calls she's going
up people want to talk to you they're
calling the house I said my Ben so I oh
yeah so you're gonna get a lot of phone
calls and you know that's good because
you're a man of the people you're the
mayor of flavortown well I will be happy
I'm from Cincinnati so absolutely no I
get it I get the frozen stuff sent in oh
you gotta set me a link to that then
because we make it here I'll put it
together for my friends yeah
I'm chilly with because the chilly
typically for most people on the west
coast Chilean beans in it so for Texas
doesn't have beans but sky but the
sensin actually doesn't that means you
get beans for anybody doesn't know what
this is you should really look it up
because you order it in different levels
of how you want to wit cheese with
onions wispy getting crazy stop five-way
yes he a guy thanks for joining us
great to be here thanks guys that sky
fear diners drive-ins times